[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cherry début alors alors ému rémy way le
plaisir à ça c'est un truc comme la
téloche
bref un truc
ouais moi aussi ça me fait un truc ben
ça j'aime bien alors ce qui l'a ramené
je tenais j'avais quinze en éducation
civique au collège c'est une petite
place au gouvernement c'est un petit et
une place vacante par oui bon comme
d'hab si on commence avec les douze
heures télé je tenais aujourd'hui à
venir soit la note du coiffeur
heureusement permis belge à naples et
missions non quoique anniversaire son
anniversaire et qu'il avait un si bon
anniversaire
c'est que tu voulais dire sur les os les
marseillais ma chérie ils sont librent
de faire ce qu'ils veulent les gens qui
rentrent dans ses émissions
merci vacciner merci merci
[Rires]
voilà c'est pour que lens et ça ça tu as
posté ça allait physiquement mais un
spot d'ossau à une bonne patate là les
grandes plaines pieter van hees et de se
marrer les amis quelques minutes on a ce
qu'il fallait pas louper
heure par heure c'est les 24 heures
tenait j'adore au cours de cette
dernière journée ce qu'il fallait pas
louper en partenariat avec l'homme le
plus chez brands en interview on y
reviendra maxime à 8h50 autant fait des
matin patrice romaine à part les signes
visiblement pour lui c'est dany boon qui
a réalisé star wars entre autres choses
dont on a parlé également de seignosse
et jean pierre elkabbach qui tient le
mic le matin et jean-pierre on sent
qu'il a fait la business school of
ouarzazate et bienvenue des lieder de
forces loyales à m sacrée idée
j'ai regardé le replay de 66 minutes sur
le bassin d'arcachon avec des images
poétiques d'abord qui nous parle des
merveilles du climat
c'est sans compter sur le tact et la
délicatesse de l'ostréiculteur plus
direct
il est rare de voir le bassin d'arcachon
réputé pour son climat tempéré couverte
un manteau de neige
maxime continue les répètent sur le
prochain prime un numéro autour du
bowling je pense qu'on va rester sur la
magie matches aux as plus ton truc
et à 18h22 on a appris que isa et
géraldine ont une fille ensemble est
ravissante comme les deux mamans vous
voyez là-bas peut-être le point pour
rebondir alors storari petit arrêter
avec ça nettoie une belle et deux dans
un instant marlène schiappa nous donnera
une nouvelle mesure à m'excuser éviter
dans tpm paix prévue se passe des trucs
sauvé la mise en foire et ça tombe d'une
camille combat d'idées dhabi j'arrive
d'euros aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
sont naturellement qu'on a décidé de se
rendre au parc des princes pour le match
psg real notre armada de journalistes de
deux stagiaires sont partis à la
rencontre des supporters des deux
équipes
regardez direction le parc des princes
donc avant le coup d'envoi les
supporters s'étaient déplacés par
milliers pour soutenir leur club
en arrivant on a rencontré des
supporters madrilènes qui venait extrait
d'espagne pour le match et figurez vous
qu'ils ont tous fait hanouna lv2 il
parle comme vous si river c'est donc
grâce à ma basse et d'autres attaques
de leur côté supporters parisiens sont
incollables sur la politique espagnole
ça fait plaisir tout droit d'espagne
je connais vraie réponse arrête ton plus
albert batteux fernandes et ouais c'est
frau non non felipe machin mais je m'en
fous on veut laisser parisien ces deux
salles deux ambiances selon les joueurs
qu'on leur présente les mains au
rétablissement au préau et un petit mot
pour ronaldo bateau est dernière du jeu
du maillot parce que maintenant les grès
et le principe est simple c'est un
supporter un fil le maillot de neymar
les yeux bandés en moins de 10 secondes
il repart avec le maillot sauf que pour
l'occasion la remplacer par un maillot
du real
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un succès
allez paris à l'école jean pierre duret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès 9h30 bien sûr de clément avec le sco
moi j'ai regardé une nouvelle émission
aussi qu'ils aient eu la chance de
recevoir une femme d'exception une femme
qui sait tout faire qui excelle dans
tous même vous même chape a malgré tout
votre planning serré à côté de cette
veine de roumanie votre vie c'est pierre
et vacances c'est vers l'amitié qui a
réussi à la recevoir en exclusivité sur
animaux télé regardez c'est petit c'est
touche à tout qui ont abordé avec succès
tous les genres la radio la télévision
l'internet animatrice chroniqueuse
blogueuse un éditorialiste romancier
biographe comédienne dans l'équipe le
règne at les compétences pour entrer au
panthéon
non mais alors le temps d'aller sur le
guide enfin sur la cabine uv de bernard
rey bellet
aujourd'hui valérie bernard a chopé tous
nos mets donc il invite tout le monde
sur animaux télé benjamin castaldi a
défait a décidé à aller parler de son
nouveau chien on sent que benji les
prises tv qui animera j'ai appris à
gérer pas de veto c'est des chiens
pendant les scélérats ce qu'on appelle
des grâces de gigue en ligue 1 dont les
molosses wiimote
pas d'essayer de rendre hommage aux
grandes stars et aux icônes de la pop
culture qui inondent instagram hashtag
gramounes on a refait les photos
regarder
iris sweetener c'est maxime déni de
réussite
emilie rattache aux skis j'espère que je
dis bien regardez qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle je vais prendre que mokhtar
évidemment quelle beauté
jennifer lopez sublime jennifer lopez
sur instagram
bon ben là c'est notre jean mimi qui
s'est collé balles de set et les plus
suivis et là encore on sait dire
physique pareil accueil mokhtar et la
dernière vraiment ma préférée c'est
rihanna pareil qui est très populaire
sur les réseaux et l'on pouvait entendre
que maxime du menu pour cette photo
[Applaudissements]
les super période leur richesse
nationale géographique c'est bien cela
prévaut de l'apprendre je suis tombé sur
un reportage sur des singes en malaisie
elle a fait des études de géographie
affaire d'état pas longtemps
alors là je sais sur les singes volants
voilà par rapport aux singes de
thaïlande s'ils sont un peu plus
abordables comme c'est vrai c'est
beaucoup c'est quoi cette histoire voilà
comment tu vas salue on habite à laval
je vous ai pu voir de nombreux et on
apprend plein de choses sur leurs
habitudes regarde le cyrano des forêts
ne laisse aucun prétendant mettre le nez
dans ses affaires
ce n'est certes en outre de caisse de
résonance quand il crie
va-t-il que je peux pas m'en pose
puisque maxime gainey était l'invité du
quart d'heure mutuelle ou qu'elles ont
découvert que maxime d'autant plus quand
on nomma taupe et c'est le diable de
tasmanie changer de casquette
c'est comme un chef d'orchestre là
dedans il faut que ça il pas par une
pompe ping pong président a tenté de
surprendre charles descamps on a cru
voir une chute durant son arrivée mais
non on est juste au max de la regardiez
de tensions non mais quand en fait je
dois rentrer 2 heures du matin et six
enfants mais j'ai un petit secret pour
être enfin bon c'est la passion c'est
pour ça qu'on aime notre maxime
attention ces deux liens aux acteurs
cyril regarder comment il salue son
public sur le générique de fin on n'a
pas vu ça depuis julio iglesias
[Musique]
quel regard
[Applaudissements]
je connais la photo de relever ce qui
motive la passion de sa part ni des
sensations là j'ai vu des hommes drôle
marley plus tôt il se passe un truc en
phase iv b vous connaissez christophe
castaner évidemment la parole du
mouvement en marche et volos très beau
gosse oui oui des bas salaires edouard
philippe jetons carnacki sens bien foutu
crabe aveu spéciaux tout le gouvernement
philippe meyer c'est edouard philippe
katerine de marquer ce but un véritable
influence heures sur le net
christophe castaner ils viennent fêter
son 100.000e abonnés sur twitter c'est
énorme
justin bieber méfie toi il arrive elle
s'appelle pauline c'est exactement la
5000ème et pour fêter ça lui a réservé
un cadeau de dingue
cheikh fall in merci merci vous avez
marre 100.000ème abonnés voulais vous
remercier vous proposer si vous en
mettent d'accord pour une visite de
l'elysée une rencontre avec d'autres
présidents à ses fiefs barack obama
peut-être pas d'accord de passer une
journée une journée de travail
leclerc a dû faire des bonnes forêt que
un ancien ministre à mon avis vu son
lapsus de président dans la tête donc de
ce pays les quatre candidats foulée les
sites et stéphane de fenoyl j'ai aussi
regardé jean jacques bourdin sur rmc
régionales ici fait un petit peu peur à
tous les politiques avant de s'y rendre
visite à poser les questions qui
dérangent indispensable critiquable
compenser vous est ce que votre pouvoir
d'achat progresser de l'économie
française ce retrait stèles et ce matin
visiblement c'est le stagiaire de
troisième qui a écrit les 6,2 à quand
une réponse à un problème qui nous
concerne tous pourquoi les chaussettes
10 par estelle dans la machine à laver
si c'est la réponse était une belle
question je dis aux gens jacques bourdin
il est quand il est 6 heures du mat
c'est leur truc qu'on lui rend candice
mahout été est avec nous bonjour quand
dix ans je pense que ce pastis
que se passe-t-il
il est
la candidate accord de deux secondes
fêter truc c'est que vous en raffolez
série on enchaîne avec quelques images
pas cher j'ai regardé les z'amours sur
france 2 et déjà je suis content hyper
content surpris et content ce matin ils
ont reçu un chanteur que j'adore que
j'aime beaucoup sur vous aussi c'est la
star internationale
on a son clip get a indiqué que sa
chérie on l'a mis les meilleurs en
chansons comme couple on dirait qu'il a
rencontré sa femme six minutes avant
l'émission génies pied reconnaît-il
ce que vous grignotez habituellement
tous les regards oui des gâteaux vous
fleurs préférées
oui les fleurs de lys le nombre de
lessives que vous faites par semaine oui
quatre votre chanteur préféré ce fruit
le basque le maquillage que vous
détestez portée oui je pense
des jeux sur tv5 monde et un journaliste
qui est un an par c'est quand on
découvre au début du sujet ce dont il
m'en parlait regarder ce père dont le
sénégalais phil mills a ont été nommés
pour étudier les conditions de retour
pascal baisser ce trône royal ça ça ment
pas et pourrir de la miss météo de ces
news alexandra blanc elle arrive plus à
cacher un peu comme quand la prof
principal ta grille est en cours c'est
une semaine très agitée qui vous attend
avec au programme ce vent de la pluie de
la neige en montagne mais les
températures qui vont rester
particulièrement 12
on retrouve des valeurs assez mitigé sur
les régions méridionales personnes sur
la demande
bonsoir été le chercheur à matignon avec
édouard fifi et d'ambiance et comme
jamais c'est la folie je vous dit les
yeux dans les yeux j'ai regardé c'est au
programme avec orpi d'avant devancé
alexandre marcellin aussi qu'avec elle
qui fait des missions et en annonçant
l'invité du jour il a faim il en pense
quoi ton frère sans le faire exprès
c'est assez rare regarde un petit peu de
chenil allons-y le solde a également
reçu robert charlebois qui tente une
vanne mais il est un peu tôt pour sophie
quand chaîne l'air de rien enfin
comment ça va attention voici le moment
beaucoup trop gênant pour ne pas quitter
plateau catimini hashtag de boulettes
bravo d'ailleurs pas ce que vous avez
fait quatre enfants avec la même femme
avec laquelle vous vous êtes toujours
heureux c'est rare dans ce métier
non on n'est plus ensemble g
[Applaudissements]